foreign
[Music]
girls ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show I'm going to hop
straight into the guest because I have
so many questions I would like to ask my
guest today is Jonathan height spelled
h-a-i-d-t you can find him on Twitter at
John height he is a social psychologist
at New York University's Stern School of
Business Jonathan received his PhD from
the University of Pennsylvania in 1992.
his research examines the intuitive
foundations of morality and how morality
varies across cultural and political
divisions he is the author of the
happiness hypothesis and the New York
Times bestsellers The Righteous Mind and
the coddling of the American mind with
Greg lucianov he has given four TED
talks and in 2019 he was inducted into
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences since 2018 Jonathan has been
studying the contributions of social
media to the decline of Teen Mental
Health and the rise of political
dysfunction he is currently writing two
books kids in space why Teen Mental
Health is collapsing and life after
Babel great title also life after Babel
adapting to a world we can no longer
share you can find him at
jonathanheit.com and on Twitter once
again at John height John nice to see
you thanks for making the time
oh my pleasure Tim very nice to meet you
so I thought we would begin with
influences
how your personality how you were
thinking has taken shape and I wanted to
begin with the name Richard schwader
could you please explain who Richard is
and how he factors into your life story
I have many mentors and sometimes I do
what I call the Gratitude parade in my
head and people flash past and there's a
string of mentors but Rick schwader is
the biggest on who I am and what I've
written so Rick schwader is a cultural
Anthropologist at the University of
Chicago and when I wrote my dissertation
at Penn I wrote it on a debate that he
was having with some other people who
study morality who were saying that
morality is always about harm rights and
Justice and schwader said well you know
yeah where you live in Cambridge
Massachusetts it is but around the world
the moral demand is much broader and
there's the ethics of community ethics
of divinity
so I plan to study to hit the two
theories against each other and I did a
study in Brazil and the us across social
classes and schwader's predictions
really came out beautifully I found big
cultural variation especially social
class variation and morality and in part
because of that I was able to get a
postdoc doing research with him so for
two years after my PhD I spent the
University of Chicago and during that
time I got a fellowship to go to India
for three months where schwader worked
in bhubaneshwar in in the state of orisa
or Odessa India and that period that
year 1993 that I hope that's a year that
we'll come back to a couple times during
this conversation because that is the
pivotal year in my life when my mind was
blown in many ways one of which was that
I was reading Buddhism and Hinduism and
then I spent three months in India and
it really was like like you know welcome
to my world and my way of thinking
because schwader is the most just
brilliant
uh iconoclastic thinking for himself
perverse in the most wonderful way
intellectual I've ever met so that's the
beginning of who Rick schwader is
perverse intellectuals that might be the
the headline of this episode so we are
going to come back to 1993 we're
definitely going to come back to
bhubaneshwar I was wondering how to
pronounce that so I'm glad you gave me
the layup in advance I'd like to visit a
motto I believe you can't believe
everything you read on the internet but
hopefully the Atlantic is reliable in
this respect
a motto of Rick's that I'd like to
unpack which is if someone asserts it
try denying it and see if it makes sense
if someone denies it try asserting it
and see if that makes sense
could you explain what this means and
maybe give an example of how he used it
or would encourage students to use it it
comes from I think a brother-in-law of
Rick's who is a dermatologist and
the dermatologist once said to him oh
Dermatology is easy
just follow this rule if it's dry make
it wet if it's wet make it dry and Rick
being again this you know this
perversity
he takes that rule and that was sort of
the way he ran his intellectual life and
so it was you know
so so when I went to Chicago it's like
the most intense intellectual square
mile in the country and you'd be in
these seminars with all these like you
know Nobel prize-winning economists and
people some would say something and Rick
would like turn it around and say like
is the opposite true and then he would
ask well you know isn't also the
opposite of what you're saying true and
that you know then you'd have to think
like wait actually yeah that is too
sometimes and so the what I take from it
is
we have such pressures to fall into line
with our team to to go with what the
dominant view is and if you do that
you're going to end up being a hack
you're going to end up being like
everyone else but if you just
automatically question things not to be
a jerk now you could do it and be a jerk
but if you just question just with pure
intellectual curiosity is it true if we
turn it around and usually it's not but
often it is and that's how you get new
insights
and so if you just have that as a habit
you'll just I mean so yeah this is
definitely good advice for anyone in a
creative industry or in the academic
world just try turning things around
so how would
just as an example Rick potentially use
this in anthropology
then that might have been a a broader
guiding tenet of his thinking that
applied to much more outside of his
declared field of expertise but is there
an example you might give for how that
would fit into anthropology or the type
of research that you were doing at the
time
so one Pops to mind but it's so
offensive that I have to start with
something else because otherwise I'll
lose your list you have to warm up the
listening hamstrings yeah no I really do
on this one so just one example is he
was in a discussion with some
psychologist because you know he's an
anthropologist but he's in cultural
psychology I'm a psychologist so he's in
a discussion with some psychologists and
they were saying well you know I mean we
have experimental evidence on this and
that's just so much more reliable than
ethnography I mean ethnography you know
an anthropologist goes someplace and
they take notes and they report but
that's just one person's view you know
experimental evidence is just much more
reliable and he turns around he says
oh really well let's see and then you
look at experiments that often don't
replicate and then you look at
anthropological accounts where often
multiple anthropologists will go
someplace and it and they will find the
same thing so the point is just he
didn't you know we you automatically
assume of course experiments with
numbers and careful procedures are
better
but he just sort of turns it around says
well actually maybe not okay that's the
easy one I hope listeners are with me on
that here's the harder one
just about the most offensive cultural
practice in the world
for anthropologists and enlightened
people is called FGM now that stands for
female genital mutilation
and anthropologists and progressives are
so tolerant so quick to say let's not
condemn other cultures let's look at it
from their point of view but on this
issue they don't and what Rick was doing
was saying in the societies where they
do this let's try to understand what
they're doing and he's totally open to
the fact that sometimes it really is a
horrible operation that you know that
deprives the woman of sexuality and I
mean so there are such a range of
practices but if you simply say
any modification on a female is should
be punishable by time in jail
then what happens is you have a variety
of African and Islamic immigrant groups
US and Canada where the mothers are put
in jail
and Rick says well let's question this
and once you see what they're doing and
sometimes it's much more equivalent to
male circumcision which is common around
the world
so anyway I'm you know I may have
actually no your listeners probably
aren't going to bolt just because of
that but I might get in trouble in other
parts of the academic world but that's
an example of his perversity if they
bolt just because of that then honestly
this is culling of the herd because let
me before you continue please hold your
place bookmark
folks part of the reason I wanted to
have John on and I respect the work that
he does is that I believe using this
type of examination and self-examination
you become more anti-fragile and you can
also see through the veil of your own
conditioning in a more effective way and
you can examine your thinking
and your assumptions vis-a-vis the
language you use the language you've
absorbed the labels that are your
defaults Etc and I think this makes you
a better more effective and hopefully
ultimately happier person who's better
contributor to society so there's my
sales pitch
wow perfect we're done here and he said
that's exactly that is exactly right
that's why I'm so grateful to Rick
because if you develop this as a habit
you become more intellectually
anti-fragile which we'll get to I hope
it helps you step out of your team it
helps you think independently and you
can see that your team does a lot of
stupid things every team does so yes
what you said what I said all right
let's then we flash back to 1993 and I
would love to revisit I'm going to write
this down sort of moral relativism and
how we might think about that and how we
either Embrace that or develop an
awareness around it so we don't you know
what let's postpone 1993 and actually
just tackle this right now so okay so
there are
a number of books I read a long time ago
when I was part of something called the
Henry Crown fellowship at the Aspen
Institute and one I am I want to say it
was
I want to say H.G Wells but I don't
think that is right who wrote an essay
called shooting the elephant or
something along these lines you may
actually be able to track back the
proper author of this but it spoke of
social pressures and during British
colonialism
this series of events that led to
someone feeling like he needed to shoot
an elephant that was causing all this
Ruckus in a village even though he
didn't want to so that that was
describing social pressures and how
those can lead to actions that we we
find immoral or reprehensible ourselves
but putting that aside that's just an
example
we also read a lot about
morality not in a structured way I think
that would
maybe stand toe-to-toe with the type of
research you do in any way but reading
various accounts of people succumbing to
moral relativism where everything is
okay because it's in a different culture
it's in a different time
how would you suggest people think about
that because on one hand I think that's
dangerous on the other hand there's
there's so much
intolerance masquerading as tolerance
and there's so many issues that I'm sure
we'll get into but just with the
subject of moral relativism
how should we how do you think about
that yes this is a great topic to tackle
in a longer discussion because it's
you know it's one of the oldest
questions in philosophy it's an
important one and it takes a little
doing
so there are a lot of intellectual
puzzles where we just sort of naturally
think about it on like a single
Dimension or as a binary and if you kind
of break it up into multiple dimensions
then you see you see Solutions so the
typical way of thinking about this is
there is morality real like is it a real
thing like you know like the laws of
physics
such that if people are behaving
contrary to it they're wrong even if
they don't know it or is morality just
you know and Herodotus in ancient Greeks
they saw this like well in this country
you know they kill their parents when
they get old and in this country they
eat pigs and they they could see that
practice is different and so well maybe
you know it's just like language it's
just like whatever you know whatever hap
whatever happens in your culture well
that's what's grammatical
but what I learned in part from schwader
and also reading a lot of philosophy
some of which he guided me to was I'll
put out a couple of Concepts so the
first is moral monism versus moral
pluralism so it's the question isn't is
there moral truth or not it's is there
one moral truth or multiple and once you
do that now you've loosened things up
because a Hallmark of my work and this
is where I departed from Rick a bit is
I've always been very influenced by
evolutionary psychology as well as
anthropology so we are evolved creatures
we are Homo sapiens and we are all Homo
sapiens and we are primates and we are
have a lot in common with chimpanzees
and bonobos so that's the evolutionary
site
and then there's also the anthropology
we vary and so when you look around the
world you don't find infinite variation
you find a few major patterns a
wonderful book dancing in the streets
history of collective Joy by Barbara
ehrenreich she says when the European
explorers went out in the you know 16th
17th century they found wherever they
went people danced around campfires had
rituals that bonded the group together
they often used psychedelic substances
they had beat Heavy Music so this is
human nature but feudal systems are also
pretty common there are a few major
patterns
and so one possibility is there's not
just one way of doing things but it's
not anything goes it's that there are
several different sort of grammatical
human forms and this actually became the
basis of my major my major work in
Psychology which is moral foundations
Theory which is my effort to say
what are the taste buds of the moral
sense because Cuisine varies around the
world you wouldn't say that the French
are wrong if they don't cook like the
Vietnamese but I think you could say
that the French and the Vietnamese are
both much better Cooks than the English
or at least you know they were
historical
it's not that anything goes there is
some truth
but here's where bringing the second
kind of abstract but really powerful
concept which is anthropocentric truth
so that means something can be true
relative to anthro into humans to who we
are so if if intelligent aliens come to
our solar system they will find that the
Earth is the third planet from the Sun
and that was true before we existed
it'll be true long after we're gone and
they would find that gold is a better
conductor of electricity than is
aluminum that was true before we were
here it'll be true you know so those are
non-anthropocentric truths there's a
fact and so many people have been on a
quest to find what are the moral truths
like and so Sam Harris who for a brief
time was my intellectual enemy we kind
of had like a feud for a few years now
we're friends we actually like each
other quite a lot but we had kind of a
feud over this because he has a whole
book of the landscape of morality
arguing that moral truths are like the
truths of chemistry and I say no
they are anthropocentric traces from a
philosopher David Wiggins
there are things that are true because
of the creatures we are so there are
things that are beautiful
because of our senses there are things
that Shakespeare is a better writer than
Kurt Vonnegut now I love reading Kurt
Vonnegut I probably enjoy it more than
Shakespeare but man I can see and almost
everyone can Shakespeare is a complete
genius at crafting words that's a fact
if aliens come here from another planet
they're not going to agree because it
doesn't make sense it wouldn't fit with
their nature anyway so putting this all
together I think what we can say is
there are moral truths and moral orders
that are emergent I am not a relativist
I am not a monist I'm a moral pluralist
there are multiple moral truths and
these truths are emergent from Human
Nature interacting as people interact in
societies okay wow I think I just did it
oh it's great and I want to
tag on a follow-up which is how do you
personally and we're going to come back
to the from Feud to friends story
because I think that could be a I think
that could be an instructive case study
plus I'm just curious because I'm I'm
friends with Sam also who is a very
formidable sparring partner yes
when you look at
Global events
how do you think about personally
human rights violations
what to accept what to oppose
yourself
as a
as a pluralist and I'm not saying that
because I'm viewing myself as the
opposite of a pluralist I'm just curious
how you personally think about
what you are proactively going to push
back against doesn't need to be outside
the U.S so because I'm an emergentist
that is I believe that morals emerge as
we interact I don't think that 50 000
years ago societies were wrong in
dividing labor between male and female
it's not like they were wrong and they
should have fixed it they should have
had perfectly like no as we now have
modern societies with labor-saving
devices and you don't have to divide
labor between male and female and there
are other ways to live so now any
society that was to say well you know
women can't do certain things only men
can't like well you know well that would
be wrong in a modern Western society
that would be unethical that would be a
violation of civil rights now when we
look at things like countries in which
the secret police grab people in the
night and take them away and torture and
kill them you don't have to be a very
Advanced Society to realize that this is
horrific this is wrong this is brutality
this is not justified by appeals to
morals so I once developed a kind of a
three-part test let me see how I can
remember it
because what we want to do is we want to
separate things like veiling or things
where they might be broadly accepted in
a culture but we're offended by them
from things like chattel slavery where
some people accept it but the victims of
it didn't accept it
so I think we we can point to things
it's often tricky we can point to things
where we can say we can criticize that
practice in that culture in extreme
cases we might even say we should try to
undermine it or try to stop it
so we'd have to go Case by case uh you
know Widow burning in India and things
like that you know which I think will
clearly fall on one side
but that's how I would generally do it
in the abstract now I think you asked me
a slightly different question that which
is more like me personally not like
philosophically right yeah so a funny
thing happened to me as I've studied
morality
which is that I almost never get angry
anymore so before 1993 I was a normal
person who got angry a lot
you know I'm pretty even tempered so it
wasn't like anger I had anger problems
I'm just saying you know I'd be like I'd
read the newspaper I'd be angry at the
goddamn you know Ronald Reagan or
whatever
and you know or someone cuts me off or
something slow so I was sort of you know
quasi type a pushy you know smart Alex
son of a [ __ ] Jewish kid is what the
neighbor ones called me
so I used to be like that and then in in
1993 I changed in part from the key
thing there was actually taking LSD for
the first time while I was studying to
go to India and reading the
bhagavad-gita and reading you know
Hinduism and Hindu philosophy and I was
at 29 years old
so here I am studying moral psychology
and all these things
and
in that year I kind of stepped out of
the Matrix I kind of stepped out of the
world that I had been living in
and that is what allowed me that year
allowed me to do the work I've done with
the rest of my life which is saying you
know what let's try to understand
progressives and conservatives in their
own terms before then I was just a
standard straight issue you know ivy
league liberal
Progressive type person
but
a roundabout way of answering your
question is I don't get mad
I look at systems and I always think how
can we make them better and systems that
are producing terrible results for human
beings should be changed so actually
I'll share so one thing this was
actually this was before my turning
point in 1987 just before grad school
I traveled alone across Eastern Europe
that's why I went to Hungary Romania and
Bulgaria and when I was in Romania where
chachesco was The Dictator
the people were literally cold and dirty
like they literally did not have soap to
clean their clothes
they did not have heat in the winter
they were kept like animals and they
behaved like animals in some sense like
you know we tried to get on a bus like
there's so few buses people push and
shove
and you know it certainly didn't make me
anger was like oh my God like
actually did make me angry because I
directed all of my Fields were against
ciao chesku and I thought if I could
kill this man with my bare hands right
now I would do it and I would love it it
was so horrific to see what this man had
done to this Society him and his half
million secret policeman
and so when he was shot in the mud in a
you know in a courtyard in 1989 I was
thrilled
so I guess that's more of a direct
answer to your question if I see someone
you know oppressing a whole society or
acting in that monstrous way not for any
moral morally legitimate reason
yeah I think we need to take action
could you tell me more about your LSD
experience why was that such a seemingly
crucial ingredient in that
turning point or that period for you
I know you've had a fair amount of
psychedelic coverage on this podcast and
I'm sure your listeners will many will
be experienced or familiar with it
so the
turning point for me it was June 11th
1993
you know like many other such
experiences one feels reborn and you
feel like you remember the day you
remember exactly when it happened
I was a postdoc in Chicago working with
schwader and I went back to Philadelphia
where I'd been a grad student and where
my ex-girlfriend were still good friends
I was there and our a lot of our friends
she got some
acid and we all did it it was my first
time doing it at the age of 29.
and the metaphor that I use
and making sense of it afterwards was it
felt to me as though as though I'd spent
all my life living in this amazing
mansion with thousands of rooms
and I loved exploring this mansion and
there and I love to travel and there
were all these rooms to explore and I
thought I was doing I was like you know
seeing all this stuff and then that
night it was like God punched a hole in
the roof reached in picked me up took me
out of the mansion and took me around
the whole world and said you thought
that was the world no this is the world
and it's you know beyond anything you
can imagine and then
you know he puts me back in the Mansion
seals up the roof and says go on
and I don't mean literally God I mean
I'm a you know I'm a Jewish atheist I
don't believe literally in God but these
experiences have really helped me
understand
the way we evolve for religion the way
almost all societies have a way of using
psychedelic plants
but you interviewed Michael Pollan so
you know what he said
so that experience certainly changed me
as a psychologist thinking about the
human mind and Consciousness and
self-transcendence and all that but it
changed me as a human being
because
afterwards it was like Petty like small
things just don't matter
it changes your perspective that's right
to say
but it also just helped me
you know what it did okay what it did
was here at the same time I was reading
the bhagavad-gita and the bhagavad-gita
there is a specific scene I talk about
this in the happiness hypothesis there's
a specific scene where Krishna gives
Arjuna a third eye to see the world as
it really is and he's like gasping for
breath he's like he can't process it but
he comes back and he wants to serve
Krishna now I didn't come back like I
want to serve my fellow man but I felt
like all my old pettiness all of that
just sort of burned off
and I just I don't know I just had a
kind of an independence like I'm not on
a team I'm just I just want to
understand what's happening and did that
then provide the fertile ground that
allowed you to learn and I'm once again
quoting from the Atlantic article the
power of rituals and
viewing a commitment to religious Purity
as a way to knit communities together in
other words
without that experience without being
plucked out of the Mansion do you think
you would have come to those conclusions
on your own in India or were they
mutually
dependent in a way
I think they were mutually dependent yes
I don't think I could have done it it
would have been just more of a standard
intellectual experience like hmm this is
interesting let me write this down in my
notebook let me try to make sense of
this
because the other piece we want to bring
in here is that in grad school I read
Emile durkheim the French sociologist
and that so and really comes out in the
Righteous Mind like Rick schwader and
Emile durkheim and Charles Darwin like
those are the three Heroes of the book
those three men their ideas just
transform my thinking
and so you put those all together
in a 29 year old brain who's having a
tremendously good time at the University
of Chicago and then going to India and
then as you're shaking it up you put in
just a tiny little bit of LSD and like
boom it comes out to a totally new
configuration so that's kind of what
happened to me in 1993. it was like the
MSG of spiritual
multi-dimensionalism just a little
little bit of pixie dust of LST yes well
you know if you think about your frontal
cortex as being
kind of like locks down between 13 and
sort of mid to late 20s it's kind of
locking down you know it's very open to
change in your teen years but it kind of
you know settles in by your late 20s
and so as it's kind of setting you know
that period of change you know had it
been five or ten years later it might
not have had that much effect yeah it
would strike me as a critical formative
window right so if you are able to slow
the setting of the concrete yes exactly
or something along those lines
metaphorically then interesting things
can happen I I will say not to spend too
much time on on the Psychedelic
component of this but
that the the loosening of self-identity
even at Advanced ages let's just say in
terminal cancer patients who are
suffering from end of life anxiety
the ability and there's some
evidence to suggest although I think
it's simplistic that the down regulation
of the default mode Network helps to
inhibit
self referential
thinking and that type of executive
function and therefore people experience
this ego dissolution or ego death but
even in a
a less extreme instance of that
it frees you from the constructs that
have been the lenses you've always worn
but not realized you've been wearing and
to that extent I I do think it allows
you to see something like for instance
these behaviors and beliefs in India
with a very different
set of eyes
than would otherwise be possible 1993 I
must say just as as coincidence
1992 to 1993 was also the year that
probably most dramatically changed my
life so we were we were having how's
that transformative experiences in the
same 12-month period of time it was my
first time
overseas and I landed in Japan as an
exchange student going to a Japanese
school living with Japanese families for
a year and that broke open my mind in
such an incredibly
at points difficult
it points difficult ways but in such a
beautifully
profound and productive way because it
forced me to question
the right what it meant to do things the
right way it was my first time being in
a country where people drove on the
opposite side of the street it's my
first time being anywhere where the
entire family shared the bath didn't
change the water and you had to clean
yourself beforehand right and the
example is just where they cool their
food by slurping it in is with great
noise as opposed to blowing on it with
exhales essos it was like this Alice in
Wonderland topsy-turvy upside down world
for me and I realized oh wow all these
things that I have assumed are just the
way
things are done
are I don't want to say arbitrary but
they're they're social conventions I
mean these are cultural
emergent patterns they're not laws of
physics
and so during that same year
I I also
really I think unlocked my ability to
start to ask ask at least questions
about my assumptions right like is that
really true do we really have to do that
yeah is this really how it works even
the structure of thought is mirrored in
language I mean Japanese is very very
different instead of being subject verb
object you know I eat the apple it's I
the Apple eat I to school go that type
of thing
and it was a it was a very productive
year I just want to pick up on that for
one moment
because I think you had your experience
at a sort of a more opportune age than
mine I mean mine worked out great but
yeah it's not you were in college at the
time right you were no I was actually
this was before Princeton this would
have been uh High School wow this was
age 15 to 16.
okay you know there's research on how we
create stories about ourselves and our
stories are wide open from about 14 or
15 is when it kind of opens up through
the mid to late 20s that's like the key
period And so you had yours right at the
beginning of that and listening to you
you know because I think so much about
Left Right differences there's research
that foreign travel makes people more
Progressive more liberal because you see
how things can be different
did it have that effect on you were you
Progressive or liberal at the time and
did it change your politics at all I am
grateful very very grateful I don't want
to you know throw my either my parents
under the bus but my dad was very vocal
about various political stuff and I
completely turned off
that listening function so I did not
this is going to be embarrassing perhaps
to admit but I effectively paid
little to no attention to politics until
perhaps 10 years ago and so I didn't
identify politically at all
I was really
issue by issue if they came up if it was
something that affected me or that I
thought I might want to change that was
the extent of my radar pickup I will say
that
in retrospect looking at my experience
probably also given the way that
Japanese Society is structured and the
availability of health care and this
that and the other thing that many of
those issues would probably be
associated with a
sort of left leaning Progressive mindset
I suppose I would have to imagine that
to be the case I don't see how it would
go the other way because I wasn't even
though in Japan there is some pretty
crazy nationalism and
super hardcore I suppose
sort of right extreme stuff I was not
exposed to that okay the idea that I was
just developing as from what you were
saying was this
you know I've long thoughts since I
wrote The Righteous Mind and since I
really tried to understand conservatism
in Libertarians and really got sort of
the wisdom from those Traditions as well
as the progress of a liberal tradition
and I've really come to see that a
functioning Society it needs a sort of
progressive Wing pushing for Change and
it needs a conservative Wing saying slow
down tapping on the brakes you know
William F Buckley you know Stanford
history yelling stuff you need both in a
healthy Society we don't have that now
our left is not liberal our right is not
conservative we're a mess but societies
need those two impulses and just from
when you were saying it didn't occur to
me it's like actually I wonder if in a
person's development you kind of need
both of those that is early on you kind
of need to like open up and travel and
see the world and question things but if
you stay that way the rest of your life
you might kind of be kind of
dysfunctional because there's
interesting research showing that it's
not age that makes people become more
conservative it's having children or
starting a business or taking on
responsibility once you take on some
responsibility you realize you know what
we actually need some rules here we need
some you know there has to be some
Authority or some hierarchy you know
they have to be punishments for cheating
so in the course of a human life maybe
there's like the opening up travel
period and then they're like okay you
got all this stuff in your head now you
have to apply it you have to kind of
focus you have to be conscientious all
right just a thought keep going yeah I
like that idea I like that idea and I've
never thought of it that way
I would also say Japan
deeply
resonated with me on a lot of levels
that my experience in the United States
did not
the cleanliness the sort of obsessive
compulsive focus on detail just the
level of
meticulous
attention to the most minute of details
which can be crippling it's not all
upside but that's so deeply
to me felt like a warm bath for maybe my
predispositions or my neuroses that it
was felt like a rebirth of sorts and I
mean I would have friends who would say
like
they'd be like they would just be like
you're not American I don't get it like
you look you're white and you look like
what you look like but
you're more Japanese than I am they
would make these jokes because it came
so easily to me culturally in a way
so to whatever extent that makes any
sense there was that
and you know I did want to ask you about
your comments
the label you used of Jewish atheists so
I am a Jewish atheist yeah and I want to
provide some context for this which is
Paul Graham who's famous for co-founding
y combinator
I had a tweet I think it was actually in
one of his essays also
along the lines of the more labels you
apply to yourself the stupider you
become something like that I'm
paraphrasing it but be careful with the
labels that you use I'm not forcing that
on you but I'm curious to know the
thinking behind Jewish atheist and I'm
friends with a writer named AJ Jacobs
who said oh yeah I love agents
what do you say like funniest yeah
writers yeah he's hilarious we said
something like
you know I am to Jewish what Olive
Garden is to Italian or something like
that was was his explanation when he
wrote the book The Year of Living
biblically which is a fantastic
fantastic book
how do you think about
being Jewish
what does that mean to you
so first we're having this discussion
the context of a Christian background
culture you know Christianity is
somewhat unusual although Islam is
similar in making it's all about your
relationship with God and faith and
Judaism is a more ancient religion and
it's very much about a story about a
tribe A group that has these ups and
downs in history and we're bound
together and of course God is a very
important part of the story but as Jews
have lived in different cultures around
the world well that shapes your identity
so you know you can be Jewish and not
believe in God just like you can be
Italian and not be Catholic right so as
an ethnic group as an identity as a
culture I'm Jewish and I recognize the
influence of just the Norms you know the
argumentativeness
you know and here we're talking
Ashkenazi Jewish I should always be
clear
that Sephardic Jews are different
they're different kinds of Jews but the
American Jewish experience is sort of
dominated by the Ashkenazi the Eastern
European immigrants all four of my
grandparents came here from Russia and
Poland and Belarus around 1907 when they
were teenagers roughly
so yeah it's part of my it's part of my
okay so I was best it's part of my
identity I guess it is but I'm playing
these days with the idea that actually
I'm an anti-identitarian I think part of
what's wrong with the country is that
America of all countries needs to be a
Melting Pot we need to have a generally
assimilationist ethos and that worked so
well for the Jews the Irish the Italians
you know all the groups that came
through Ellis Island into an
assimilationist 20th century America it
worked out fantastically well so anyway
that's just we can follow that down in a
moment the identitarianism so you can be
Jewish by identity and not believe in
God in fact I'd like to do this formula
I always think if you ask a Christian do
you believe in God
usually if they've identified as a
Christian they're going to almost you
know they're usually going to say yes
okay try asking that with 10 Jews like
maybe one of them will say yes and maybe
two or three will say no and the rest
will say well it depends I mean do you
mean this do you mean that like well you
know sort of maybe so being Jewish is
different religiously than being
Christian or Muslim
that makes sense that makes sense to me
do you as an atheist
build in any
rituals
or traditions
from the Jewish lineage let's say
okay so this helps me clarify atheist is
not part of my identity I said I'm a
Jewish atheist but atheist is not part
of my identity okay I'm just you know
I'm just a Jew who doesn't believe in
God and that maybe was part of my clash
with Sam Harris because that was this
was during the time of the you know the
new atheists and there was a combative
movement and I didn't want to be part of
that you know I thought there was a lot
to respect about religion and so I would
do the schwader thing you know which is
okay you're making these claims about
religion well let's see you know is that
you know let's turn that around is that
really true
but back to your question
so no I don't incorporate any rituals
that are related to my being an atheist
but I do yeah I do have some rituals and
this is actually almost more comes from
like stoic Traditions just that the
stoics
advise doing a morning routine an
evening routine
meditations on philosophy in the morning
and then kind of a taking stock at night
so I I usually try to do that just as an
individual you know practice to just set
my priorities and reflect on on my day
and what I'm doing
and you know minimally Jewish in the
sense of like we go my family so my wife
is korean-american but she was very
happy to have us raise our kids with
some Jewish identity my son had a bar
mitzvah
and so you know we go to synagogue on
the high holy days we like Shabbat
candles and have a family meal on Friday
so fairly minimal but it is is important
I do have a feeling that something was
passed down to the generations to me and
I don't want to break the chain it's a
very valuable thing that was passed down
to me and I want my children to have a
sense that they're part of that chain
let's
talk about from Feud to friends
with Sam Harris okay and I know you
described it in passing but what was the
feud and then the more interesting part
of that is I shouldn't say interesting
but the part that I want to focus on is
how did you go from that to then friends
because that is feuds are where things
start and end a lot of the time these
days and maybe forever given human
nature but certainly online
people get rewarded probably more for
feuding than they do for being friendly
so could you just describe
that experience please yeah and that's
kind of fun to reflect on it so back
when Sam really burst onto the scene you
know he's a great writer and a beautiful
writer and he was so persuasive you know
writing those first two new atheist
books we would be invited to a lot of
the same conferences because I was
beginning to write about how religion
you know I'm a naturalist I don't you
know I believe we evolved to be really
you know I don't believe it's God who
made us religious
but you know religion does all these
good things I was saying and so we'd be
invited to conferences together there
was like the beyond belief conference
Sam and you know all the other new
atheists went the first year and then
Sam and me wanted to others went the
second year and wherever I would appear
with Sam or wherever we would Clash in
writing Sam would always use this
rhetorical technique of basically saying
so John height would say that human
sacrifice among the Aztecs is a good
thing because it finds people that you
know so he would always accuse me of
like supporting atrocities and by the
third or fourth time he'd done this I
was okay I said before I don't get angry
I was kind of pissed and so I did kind
of a dirty lowdown trip yeah yeah there
must be some decorum there must be some
decorum yes
so I did something I'm a little
embarrassed by it was kind of it was
clever but a little embarrassed now I
did a kind of an academic trick which is
one thing that bothered me about Sam you
know he has a PHD but he wasn't really
socialized as an academic he was writing
more as a
rhetorician you know a public arguer
and he would use very strong language
always this and never this and certainly
this and so I said you know what
let me take all of Sam's writings and
feed them through
there's a program that analyzes word use
by Jamie Panabaker anyway you feed it
through and it counts like certainly
always Never And so there's a category
called certainty
and so I fed the text of Sam's books
through and you get a number how certain
is Sam and the couple things like that
and then I said in the other new atheist
and then I fed in Rush Limbaugh and
Glenn Beck and I put a whole bunch of
them in and then I put in me and David
Sloan Wilson who was also with me
arguing that religion is nuanced effects
and it turned out that Sam was higher on
certainty words than you know Glenn Beck
and Rush limp and all those people so I
just wrote this up in a blog post and I
showed graphically that Sam is actually
more certain of himself than these
people that he's always lambasting so it
was a kind of a dirty trance but it was
funny
yeah and then I think I offered like I
called it the moral psychology Prize or
the Sam Harris press or something that
oh yeah oh yes I forgot a crucial thing
Sam wrote his book The moral landscape
saying you know morality is a fact and
he offered money I think it was money to
whoever could persuade him otherwise and
then I wrote my essay
I bet that no one will be able to
persuade Sam otherwise and here's why
and then I went then I showed that how
certainly is so I kind of put him in a
bind so that's how it started so then we
kind of had like a little you know cold
we just kind of ignored each other for a
while
and I my recollection of how it ended
was you know Sam Sam's incredibly
courageous and is not a partisan and he
thinks for himself and he does things
that make people hate him on both sides
and I really do respect him for that and
it was something I think it was he said
something about Islam and he was being
lambasted and I can't remember whether I
like you know retweeted something or
said something I put up some like little
tiny show of support for him I think
that's how it went and then Sam
acknowledged and thanked me for it and
what happened was well Feud was in like
2014. and that was back before
everything went insane and around 2014
2015 everything went insane
and there was this incredible you know
explosion of illiberalism on campus and
in the academic world the intellectual
world and Sam and I were then actually
both on the same side which is we
believe in being reasonable and using
evidence so we you know we ultimately
were sort of natural allies and whoever
first gave a little show of support for
the other was like okay yeah you know
what I like you so and so I've been on
this podcast twice and I've just great
admiration for him
he's a very very smart cookie I am also
a very big fan of
Sam
and
flash boil 2014 2015. what the hell
happened
what contributed to things suddenly
hockey sticking and insanity could it
have been predicted I don't think so
because so I find these like big ideas
that really help me think and so I'm
going to put another one out there which
is a complex dynamical system and is
this something you've talked about on
your show before
so complex dynamical systems so the
human mind is really good at thinking
about mechanical systems machines things
moving in space
we have sort of two brains we have sort
of two minds we have a mind that's
really good at thinking about objects
moving in space and so there's Popular
Mechanics for people like doing that and
we're really good at thinking about
people moving in Social space and
forming alliances and betrayals and soap
operas and all that and so there's
People magazine for people like doing
that
those two things we're really good at
but there are a lot of things in our
world that are nothing like that
like the weather the economy there are
complex dynamical systems where you
can't even in principle predict what
it's going to do because it's a chaotic
complex system and you can change
parameters and you can kind of predict
which way things are going to go but you
can't really know and when you change
parameters you can suddenly get a phase
change
and
so mechanical systems are easy to
understand complex dynamical systems are
very hard
but we live within them and so what
happened I believe is that we hit a
phase change it actually began in 2014
but it blew up in the academic world in
2015 and so this is what I've called
metaphorically the fall of the Tower of
Babel
so if you simply wire people up if you
just connect people more and more
you think that's good right
we always thought that you know from the
Roman roads and the first telegram
cables or the Pony Express I mean it's
good to have more communication that's
generally a good thing but it could have
some problems and it might be that you
just get to a point where everyone's so
connected that everyone is yelling or
everyone's mad at everyone so it might
just be that there's more and more
connection but I think it's something
else what I've come to believe in trying
to understand what the hell happened
is it's the nature of the connection
changed after 2009 so once
we used to call social network sites
they connected people so you could use
Facebook to communicate with your
friends from high school that was great
there's no problem there but in 2009
Facebook introduced the like button
Twitter introduced the retweet button
Facebook copied it with the share button
so social media isn't just connecting
people anymore and we stopped talking
about them as social networking sites we
start using the word social media
platform now it becomes about
performance
and it becomes much more viral much more
explosive it's not about me talking with
you it's about me talking at you in the
hopes that my my slam on you will get
picked up by others and that will make
me famous that will get me prestige and
once everyone's motivated to do that or
I should say once 10 of people are
motivated to do that
the system develops new properties that
were not there in 2008 yeah and most of
us most of your listeners if they're old
enough can remember you know it used to
be an amazing place like the internet
was amazing social media was amazing
Twitter was playful and fun and they're
still it's still that in heart but it
just became much nastier one of the key
Innovations I believe was what Facebook
called threaded comments so it used to
be you know if Barack Obama puts up uh a
tweet in his first term he puts it up
and people can respond and that's it
they just respond and that's it you can
say you know you can say you're stupid
or you're terrible and that's it you say
that
but in 2014 Facebook said how about to
increase engagement how about we let
everyone fight with everyone everywhere
so if Barack Obama puts up a Facebook
post in his second term or after 2014
someone can say you know go back to
Kenya and then someone else can say to
that commenter no you are a fascist and
then before you know you've got people
fighting in the comments so it's like
those scenes in a bar room brawl you got
two people having a Face-Off and
suddenly everyone's breaking bottles in
everyone's heads that I believe is what
happened in 2014 2015 yeah and democracy
is unsustainable institutions are
collapsing universities are going crazy
so we're now in the post Babble world
where we can't have any shared
understandings of Truth we can't have
any shared stories hence the title of my
forthcoming book
life after Babel adapting to a world we
may never again share
do you have thoughts on what we can do
from
a proactive
incentive perspective
to I don't want to say reverse some of
these Trends but to redirect the
currents slightly in different
directions and you mentioned Chicago one
thing that really jumped out to me this
is quite a few years ago now I want to
say but when the sort of woke Supremacy
virus started spreading throughout
Academia and
fragility was being reinforced and
tripled down upon
I want to say it was the University of
Chicago put out a letter to say like we
we are actually going to go in the
opposite direction and it was it was
notable to me because a number of
friends of mine who are alumni from
uchicago said this is the first time in
10 years that I've given money to the
university yeah so there are I guess a
number of questions in this word cell
that I'm throwing at you the first is
why do you think uchicago was able to do
that then or willing to do it and would
they be willing to do it again now
right just to understand the incentives
because I've seen so many people lose
their posts doesn't really just seem to
matter how high up you are if you can be
removed by the trustees you are
vulnerable
or whatever mechanism exists for
replacing the the top brass
and then separately let's focus on the
academic side first and then we can look
at the
at the technological side and maybe the
business side
so in the academic world
why do you think it was possible for
uchicago to do it then could they do it
now and is it possible to
create some type of counterbalance or
change incentives such that this doesn't
continue to go in the direction it's
going so I can't answer that question
until I explain the Dynamics that have
made leaders cave throughout the
intellectual World throughout the let's
call it we have Democratic institutions
that we have epistemic institutions
epistemic meaning in search of knowledge
so that's preeminently the universities
in journalism
museums other things like that why have
they all fallen in the same way
so let me start with that and then we'll
get to Chicago so
I've been trying to figure this out like
every day I've been obsessed with this
since it started in 2014. that's when
Greg Luciano came to me Greg is the
president of the foundation for
individual rights and education and he
said John weird stuff is happening on
campus students are suddenly asking for
protections from books word speakers
ideas before then it was always
administrators and so Greg says like you
know what's going on the students seem
to be explaining these things using the
same cognitive distortions that I
learned to not do when I was treated for
depression Greg suffers from depression
and he learned cognitive behavioral
therapy so anyway
I thought Greg's idea was brilliant
somehow universes are teaching students
to think to catastrophize over
generalize mind reading all these
distortions
so that starts in 2014
and then it's really the fall of 2015
especially after the Halloween incident
at Yale where the students demand that
Nicholas christakis apologized for a
thoughtful caring letter that his wife
had written to the students of Silliman
college and then the president of Yale
Peter salave never backed up the
christakis they demanded that they'd be
fired and the president just gave the
students everything they demanded that
he couldn't give them everything but he
really made a big show of saying yes
you're right and that launched a wave of
protests around the country and it
always goes the same way which is a
charge from a student that something
that was said was insensitive about race
gender lgbtq and then there's never a
finding of information it's
blows up on Twitter or other channels
and then within a day or two the
person's fired no no due process and
we've this keeps going it happened at
the New York Times it just happened at
the association for psychological
science here an editor may have made a
mistake it looks like he probably didn't
follow a good process but again there's
a mob and then the leadership gives you
so that's what's been happening why are
they all caving I'm just trying to think
of the incentives
because it doesn't happen everywhere
right there are some counter examples
so it happens when you get
moral homogeneity so you get an
institution where the great majority or
almost everybody's on one side
and so in epistemic institutions it's
always going to be the left now you can
have a craziness on a far on an all
right-wing institution but there aren't
any institutions on the right that are
as high you know they have so little
diversity as those on the left on the
left it's often the case that there's
not a single person on the right I
rarely encounter a conservative in the
academic world there are very few
whereas when I've spoken at military
installations or you know if you have a
right-leaning thing there's still going
to be some liberals there anyway so you
have moral homogeneity which is a
crucial background variable moral
homogeneity you have students so usually
it's members of J oh you have gen Z so
the charges are usually from gen Z or
late millennials
making a charge that the leadership is
vulnerable to because leadership is
usually older white liberals
and it's backed up with with a barrage
of darts so a dart is anything that
someone can do to hurt someone else you
can launch a dart on Twitter you can
make an accusation you have no liability
for it so what you see is these leaders
suddenly they're in morally homogeneous
politically homogeneous
institutions
they are attacked with darts they cave
instantly it's very painful
they cave insulin that just encourages
the darters to to go further
so I call this a recent Atlantic article
I called the structural stupidity that
is you can have very smart people but
you only get smart when bad ideas will
be challenged and if a bad idea so for
example that you know at universities we
all have bias response teams so if I say
anything and a student objects they can
report me in three ways and they that
number is posted in the bathrooms it's
on the back of all the ID cards like
here's 9-1-1 here's campus safety here's
the bias response line if you're
offended call this number this is a
really really bad idea or at least
there's no evidence that it's a good
idea but it's done everywhere it's done
everywhere because no one dares oppose
it like nobody in the faculty said it
will say well wait a second do we really
want to do this everyone's just like oh
yeah let's let's do this this will be
anti-racist
so you get structurally stupid
communities and they all fold in exactly
the same way this is what happened at
the New York Times with the firing of
James Bennett it's the same thing
everywhere why was Chicago different two
reasons one is Chicago so every
institution has its own moral resources
every institution has a sense of
identity and Chicago is unique
in having this really intense
intellectual like really high
intellectual identity and when I was
there
students wore t-shirts University of
Chicago where fun goes to die and played
by magazine ranked them the worst party
school in America you know 300th out of
300 don't go to Chicago and they were
proud of it so if they begin with this
intellectually intense identity
the background and then the other
crucial element was leadership they had
Robert Zimmer that's it
Robert Zimmer personally was calling
[ __ ] on all this stuff this is not
who we are this you know the caving the
demands the outrage mobs like no we're
going to talk about ideas here so Robert
Zimmer single-handedly sort of said like
No And that letter that you referred to
was not from him it was by a dean of
students who sent a letter to
prospective students who are coming to
the to Chicago and he said at Chicago we
don't do safe space now he misspoke or
he that was a mistake because if if the
gay students or LGBT students want to
have a club where they have certain
discourse rules great free association
let him what the dean meant to say was
our classrooms are not safe spaces in
our classrooms people can criticize what
you say
so and if you have that then you don't
have structural stupidity if we're
looking at structural stupidity I start
to think about structural Dynamics and
the
ways in which people are vulnerable or
less vulnerable to losing their posts
right let's just say you are Brian
Armstrong CEO of coinbase and the
company is doing well and you want to
remove and I don't want to speak for him
but this has been very well covered you
want to put out a letter that
effectively says this is our mission if
you're aligned with this Mission great
but our our we cannot be responsible for
every cause or world event that pulls a
direction and a given velocity towards
whatever outcome you might want
therefore
if you would like to discuss these
things and feel like it should be done
at work go elsewhere we're going to give
you a fantastic severance package
part of the reason you can do that aside
from I think being very courageous
thinking for himself and being willing
to take a lot of flack in the short term
in the long term best interest of the
company
putting that aside
he's also I think in doing that unlikely
to get fired right it would take the
board of directors to remove him and
then there's the question of well who
would we replace him with who would
actually be a good enough operator
to do a better job gonna be very tough I
suppose what I'm wondering is within
academics do you think there's anything
that can be done to provide
protections or safety nets such that
more people can actually take a counter
position
yes so let's just start by understanding
the complex dynamical system of a
company in a capitalist economy so
all the stuff that started on campus in
2015.
Greg and I wrote about it in the
coddling American mind we were going to
have a chapter on the coddling goes to
work but there weren't enough stories in
2017 when we were finishing the writing
so we closed down the book and then in
2018 it all starts blowing up all this
stuff you know because gen Z graduates
they move into the corporate world and
they do the same stuff there that they
were doing on campus you know the
accusations that someone someone wore a
hat that offended me you have to punish
them
this is an HR issue so all that stuff
starts around 2018 2019.
and then of course in the summer of
George Floyd the political activism
intensifies you know for again
understandable reasons but in that
summer
almost all businesses it seems put out a
statement on black lives matter now that
was an exceptional summer exceptional
event but that then led to pressures
that led to a reorientation of much of
corporate America at least progressively
oriented progressively in the companies
much like what happened to us in the
academy in 2015-2016 so it was very very
similar but the difference is that
companies actually have to make money
they actually have to be tied to the
real world so if they do things that
backfire that cost a lot of money
without any benefit like you know
mandatory diversity training there you
know it takes a lot of money there's not
really any evidence that makes anything
better
at some point reality hits companies
whereas universities are different
they're not like that there is no
reality the leading ones have gigantic
endowments no matter how bad the service
is parents all over the world want their
kids to go to the top 10 or 15 American
universities and it doesn't matter what
happens you know the product can suck
but the demand for it is infinite so
universities are not tied to reality in
the way that businesses that's the first
thing second thing is that most
businesses are not as uniform as
universities of course Armstrong I
presume he's right of Center or
libertarian you know I don't want to
speak for him I'm not conservative yeah
I'm not I honestly have no idea my point
is that a number of right-leaning CEOs
did that he was the first big one and
it's called the mission focused movement
that you know what our company is not
here to fix everything in the world
we're here to provide a great service
for our customers so Mission focus and a
few right-leaning companies dibs at and
the big the one that really changed
things then was when Netflix did it
because Netflix is a very Progressive
company hugely important culturally and
when the Netflix CEO says something
similar which was if your values mean
that you can't work on certain projects
maybe you shouldn't be working at
Netflix
and I speak to a lot of managers and
CEOs and leaders and like oh they were
so thrilled because almost all leaders
hate this woke stuff almost all
University presidents hate it makes
their lives hell
so in the business world
they're able to push back and they have
been so the pendulum is swinging back in
business I don't yet see a sign on
campus of a pendulum swinging back
I think it will happen eventually the
complex dynamical system is much more
conducive to a kind of a crazy
ideological thing divorced from reality
on campus
but the way it's going to break I
believe is things get sort of tense
enough unpleasant enough wasteful enough
and then some school is going to break
and I originally thought Chicago was the
school and lots of schools would follow
and they didn't nobody followed Chicago
I mean Mitch Daniel's at Purdue but
that's a different story he's a
conservative
so I'm on The Advisory Board of the
University of Austin are you involved
with it at all it's in your hometown I'm
there I'm not involved but I have some
passing familiarity for people who don't
have any familiarity can you just
explain what it is so it's a University
founded
on the idea of we're going to rethink
what a university should be and Pano
canelos is the president he was the
president of St John's College in
Maryland it's not going to have all the
administrators all the bells and
whistles it's going to really be focused
on Classics education at the beginning
but then practical As you move on so a
lot of not just like take a course get a
credit for sitting in a seat but do
things as part of a team to solve a
problem so it's going to be you know
given that higher ed now is so expensive
and is not as good as it used to be the
product is just not as good it's not as
much fun it's not as rigorous
so given that the product is declining
while the price goes up Austin is
developing a model where the price is
much much lower the product is a hell of
a lot of fun it's very exciting
and now it's just one University
but the idea is it's going to be a model
for a lot of other universities to
either change or be founded because I
think we do need disruption and
Innovation we need alternatives
we can't just have the one sort of Ivy
League model of top universities and
they're all making the same mistakes at
the same time
I have a number of questions that that
float to the surface and I apologize for
what is going to be a very inelegant way
of posing them but I'm going to give you
a menu of options and I'd love for you
to choose whichever is of the greatest
interest
so something that came to mind was how
you have
preserved your ability or insured your
ability to
speak very openly about these things by
maybe diversifying your identity and
professional career so not just teaching
but also books and
and so on speaking I assume so you have
a number of backup parachutes I would
say perhaps in a sense maybe maybe
that's something to talk about but what
I wanted to ask you specifically related
to University of Austin because I did do
a bit of reading related to it in prep
for the Neil Ferguson conversation
it seems like and I don't know if this
coverage is accurate but that
some people have been start to finish
strong supporters there are and have
been a number of very notable names
involved so I encourage people to check
it out it seems like there have also
been people who agreed to be on advisory
boards and so on who have folded
or broken rank with
with public criticism
how would you describe the the reception
and some of those Dynamics if if what
I'm reading is accurate
we're in a space
that is heavily politicized there's a
lot of attacks almost all on Twitter and
social media most professors are
reasonable most professors are you know
left Center left they believe in free
speech they believe in that in class we
should talk about ideas so wherever you
go most people are reasonable but the
Dynamics are such that if you stick your
neck out the small Fringe of academic
Twitter is going to call you racist
sexist transfer whatever and and for a
while that was really scary
and I think now
it's kind of like the boy who cried wolf
10 million times you know once
everyone's accused of racism sexism
transphobia islamophobia
I think now people are just so exhausted
that I think now it's a little easier
to stand that Fringe on Twitter
when the University of Austin was
announced
the I think there was a mistake in that
some of the you know some of the
original material was a little bit
pugnacious like and it sounded sort of
like this is going to be anti-woke
University and once any particle is
labeled like anti-woke like now suddenly
it's like oh you know now it's you so I
think there was a little brouhaha I
think that was a one fumble the people
running it made in what was otherwise I
think a very good launch I mean I think
they really explained well what it's
going to be about so I wish they hadn't
done that because
what I've learned from study morality is
in a polarization spiral or a culture
War
the harder you hit your enemy the
stronger they get and so you don't win
by punching them really hard you can
never destroy them in a real world you
can literally kill them and take their
land but in a culture where you can't do
that
and so I think it's really important
this is what we've done at heterodox
Academy so I founded an organization
called heterodox Academy it's now run by
John tomasi as our president and our
attitude is we're not here to fight the
culture War
we're here to build great things we're
here to help people remember why they
love universities why universities are
so important and I think Austin is doing
that
so
so I think early on you know it was a
new thing and it wasn't clear what it
was and there were one or two people who
left The Advisory board at that early
stage
but I think now it's settled in it's
being successful it's had a class so
it's not it doesn't yet have a full year
of student had a summer program
and I think we need variation we need
Innovation and so I'm actually very
excited about it yeah I agree I'm
excited to watch it could you say a bit
more about header docs Academy oh I'd
love to
so I gave a talk in 2011 I was invited
by the president of the society for
Personality and Social Psychology to be
part of a panel at our annual conference
on the future of social psychology and
you know we talked about my stepping out
in 1993 I'm not on a team I was still
very much a Democrat I voted for
Democrats but by the time I was writing
the Righteous Mind I began to really
take seriously that you need
Viewpoint diversity you need
conservatives and Libertarians you can't
just have a bunch of progressives
studying psychology you get bad results
and so I gave a talk on how you know
this is a problem this is a problem we
don't have any conservatives and I went
through all kinds of methods of finding
a conservative social psychologist I
couldn't find any and I finally found
one
so I gave a talk on this and I wasn't
kicked out of the field people actually
said oh you know you're right like
actually this would help us if we had
some political diversity so that was
2011. and this was just a problem about
the faculty and some other some other
professors who were there liked what I
said they said yeah we think it's a
problem too so we wrote a paper together
on laying out more formally and I think
the title was political diversity will
improve social psychological science
so this is a straight academic faculty
project and then it turns out actually
the same problem was happening in law
schools and sociology in a lot of fields
their research was not reliable because
of Orthodoxy political Orthodoxy so we
all got together and said hey let's put
up a website and Nick Rosencrantz a law
professor at Georgetown came up with the
name heterodox Academy it's the opposite
of Orthodox Academy Orthodox means
straight one there's only one way of
thinking heterodox means there should be
a variety of ways of things we need that
in order to be successful
so we put up the website we started it
as a Blog
around like September 12th of 2015 and
very right after that Yale blew up the
universities blew up and suddenly was
like wait a second we thought this was
just a faculty thing but now it turns
out like the campuses are going insane
the students are behaving in a strange
way they're saying everything is
violence everything is danger
everything's a threat
so heterodox Academy Grew From just this
faculty project to really being much
more about University culture
to do our jobs we have to have not just
Viewpoint diversity but a sense of a
sense of Grace a sense of Tolerance a
sense
of intellectual humility and generosity
we have to be able to think together we
have to have people like Rick schwader
saying okay you asserted that well let
me try the opposite and then they don't
get fired for doing it
so that's what we're trying to do
heterodox Academy now has their we have
a couple of big projects one is
one is we're branching out and having
campus communities
we're going to be working directly on
campus with our many we have about 5 000
members and I invite everyone who's
listening here if you are a professor
or an administrator if you're an Insider
to universities if you're part of the
community that is tasked with preserving
these precious institutions
please go to
heterodoxacademy.org and click on about
us and join you can see our membership
it's free we have 5 000 professors
as members and we're equally divided
Left Right libertarian we're sort of all
over the map
and it's a wonderful Community if you
remember when it was fun when there were
jokes and exciting ideas if you remember
when everything wasn't so dangerous
please join us because that's what we're
trying to recall and restore
who are some of the thinkers who have
informed how you think about
intellectual heterodoxy and I will throw
one out there John Stewart Mill oh yeah
and is this quote
from Jon Stewart Mill he who knows his
own side of the case knows little of
that he who knows only ozone side of the
case only his own side of the case knows
little of that exactly that's right so
Jon Stewart Mill is the patron saint of
viewpoint diversity one of the greatest
works of the liberal tradition is on
Liberty it's a kind of a long book with
dense Pros but chapter two is the key
chapter on diversity of thought or
freedom of thought Liberty of thought I
think it is
so at heterox Academy we took that
chapter it's 15 000 words we cut it in
half we edit it down so you have a
shortened version much easier to read
and it's beautifully illustrated by a
brilliant artist Dave ciccarelli so if
you go to heterodoxacademy.org
Mill
it's a free ebook you can buy it on
Amazon for twenty dollars but we put out
a free ebook because we want students to
read it
and it'll really I mean it really just
makes the case that you need Viewpoint
diversity if you want to get smart if
you want to figure things out an amazing
thing happens and is what I've really
taken apart from studying John Stewart
Mill is
if you want to improve your thought the
world will help you if you ask and if
you go to people who disagree with you
and say Here's what I'm thinking where
am I wrong they'll tell you and so when
Greg and I wrote the kotlin the American
mind
I paid seven social justice activists to
read it paid to meet 700 and they read
it and they gave me their comments and
their criticisms one or two of them were
you know we're kind of pissed off or
annoyed but the others were actually
like oh you know this is interesting we
really you know we really engage with
each other and they made the book better
so you really need to seek out criticism
you need to seek out people who differ
from you and then actually you'll get
smarter
have you found other people who have
studied morality to
defuse or defang their anger in the same
way that you experienced it yourself is
that a pattern that you've observed in
other people
what the ability to defang the anger to
like get past it right your description
of how you
I wouldn't say cease to be angry but
lost your anger
in the course of studying morality is
that something that you have seen
replicated in other people oh yes oh yes
so first of all the Buddhists and the
stoics these are the two most
concentrated wisdom traditions on Earth
I believe my first book the happiness
hypothesis was about I read all the
ancient wisdom I could find took out all
the psychological claims so chapter four
of that book is on the ancient idea you
know why do you see the spec in your
neighbor's eye when you cannot see the
plank on your own we're all Hypocrites
so following certain wisdom Traditions
especially Buddhism and stoicism but
also Christianity Judaism
you find these injunctions to go past
good and evil to be more more tolerant
so this is just sort of the progression
of wisdom that
most great cultures have realized you
also see it in a lot of people I think
as people get older so at least in men
our testosterone levels like they
they're really high in the teens 20s and
then they'll sort of go down steadily
and that steady drop I think it also
mirrors the drop in violent criminality
and I believe it also mirrors the drop
in like aggressive rock music like it's
you know I used to like always need loud
music and as I get older I don't
but I think it's just it also it's a
calming so you know young men are more
passionate
and moralistic perhaps and then as you
as you get older you get kind of calmer
but there are lots of Paragons of this
Daryl Davis being perhaps the preempt
you know one of the preeminent ones
Daryl Davis a black musician Blues
musician
who was playing in a bar and ended up
sitting next to a Ku Klux Klan member
he's conversing with the guy and rather
than getting upset or angry or running
away he listens to him listens to him
gets in a conversation with him and they
develop a friendship and he gets the guy
to give up his robe and leave the clan
and he's done this hundreds of times
well how do you spell Daryl's name Daryl
Davis yeah
d-a-r-y-l or is it double r Daryl Davis
is d-a-v-i-s he's got one or two TED
Talks that are great and he's got a book
or two so Daryl Davis what an inspiring
example of how
is your goal is your goal to impress
everyone else with your righteous
reaction well if so then you should get
angry and you should yell and scream and
you should post things on Twitter or is
your goal to actually change someone
if your goal is to change someone listen
to them try to understand them you
listen to them like they've never been
listened to before and then an amazing
thing happens then they'll listen to you
and so that's really the magic and this
is also Dale Carnegie this is so many
wise people that the things we do to
show off our morality for others end up
isolating us and making us stupid and
unhappy often times happy yeah Anchor's
not a negative emotion anger in the
brain is looks more like a positive
emotion because a shared anger is
thrilling and that's part of what's
driving us off a cliff as a country
what would you say are these some of the
conclusions or observations made in the
happiness hypothesis that you revisit
most often or underscore for yourself
and what is your set point if you have
one
so the set point question
is easy that just refers to the fact
that happiness is heritable and
identical twin separated birth will tend
to be similarly happy and my set point
is sort of right in the middle I'm not
born I'm generally optimistic but I'm
I've been depressed at a couple points
in my life I'm not very prone to it but
I've had I've had some
and so I'm sort of in the middle
but the level of happiness that you live
at is not your set point where you live
is sort of a range around your set point
depending on a few conditions
so and the those conditions are
basically love and work Sigmund Freud
said love and work if you're doing well
in those you'll be at the top end of
your range so I teach a core set at NYU
a graduate seminar called work wisdom
and happiness
and it's a positive psychology class but
in the last year I've sort of readjusted
this syllabus
I've rewired the course so that the
title could be smarter stronger more
sociable and so we have sections on how
do you get smarter and you do that it
turns out the big thing you do turn off
your notifications get your attention
back read Johan Harry's book stolen
Focus so you can make yourself 10 or 15
IQ points smarter if you can regain
control your attention and cut down on
the moralism those are the two big steps
so how do you get smarter how do you get
stronger that's
that's the causing of the American mind
anti-fragility Naseem taleb
you get stronger by challenging yourself
by exposing yourself to threats and
dangers within limits that you then
surmount and we have to do this with
kids
and how do you get more sociable well
it's actually some of the same skills
but the main one is really listen to
people
and you can't do that as long as you're
always distracted as long as you're
always on your phone
so there are some really easy things you
can do and then the students learn to do
some harder things but if they can get
smarter stronger and more sociable
then they will be more successful at
work and in relationships and if they're
more successful in work and
relationships then I promise them on the
first day then they will be happier
because that's how you live at the high
end of your set range is by having your
love and your work go well
is this course in any capacity available
online or could it be made available
online
oh any aspect maybe maybe a reading list
maybe questions so the syllabus is
online and
you know what I should do something like
that so it was just a seminar at Stern
with 35 MBA students twice you know two
sections a year and I've just raised it
to 55 students while teaching more
sections
I should put something up you know what
I'm going to start a sub stack oh this
is oh my God this is great I'm actually
going to start a sub stack in January I
can't believe I didn't think of this the
sub stack people would kill me for not
announcing this like yeah so it's going
to be called the after Babel is the name
of the sub stack and I can just put up
whatever I want
I used to blog at righteous mind.com but
that was not much so I'm going to start
blogging and I thank you for that Tim I
will put some whatever I can put easily
online or in there I will put there at
least the reading listen to syllabus
amazing and eventually maybe I could
tape the lectures or do something to put
it uh yeah I'll think about it is there
a department and number for the class
something that people could
look for online no because well I'm not
sure how that would work in MBA programs
but I'm just thinking you know the class
that I used to visit at Princeton was
ele 491 right high-tech entrepreneurship
so it made it easy to find oh well
there's no point in them finding it
because it fills up with Stern students
you know even if you're edit NYU but not
at Stern you can't take it
so all my stuff is at jonathanite.com
I will find a way to put it on my site
and then I think our discussion might
air before New Year's but the sub stack
isn't going to be up until late January
probably okay
I'll do something thank you and it's
easy for us to put in the show notes so
once anything is available we can add it
to the show notes at tim.blog podcast
and people can find you by just
searching h-a-i-d-t
let's talk about
religion and happiness so
I have observed I'm not the only one
generally speaking I would say the
let's just say self-described
rational materialist
left-leaning
folks
to be pretty unhappy
overall and I have found very smart
very thoughtful
people who would identify as religious
to on average be
quite a bit happier and I know happy can
be a slippery term but if we're
looking at work and love work and
relationships
they seem to check a lot of boxes very
well but it seems to me and I'm just
gonna
speak for a second here that
with religion you also remove a lot of
uncertainty decision fatigue Paradox of
choice
that makes life
less of a death by a thousand paper cuts
and maybe that also contributes to
General sense of well-being that many of
your decisions are more automated
perhaps people you spend time with
perhaps your weekly structure the
architecture of your life
how
how do you think about this what have
you seen in your observations and
studies with respect to religion and
happiness and are there ingredients from
religion that secular folks can borrow
to get some of that upside
so there's a huge amount of research on
happiness and who's happy and the two
big things that really come out
consistently are religious people are
happier and married people are happier
religion and marriage are the two giant
demographic factors or quasi-demographic
factors that that seem to go with
happiness
and then there's a lot of question as to
why why does religion make people
happier it might be what you said it
makes you know you don't have to think
about things you have a sense of meaning
you don't worry about the after like
whatever it is no it turns out when they
look when you do empirical studies of
what elements of religious people's
lives correlate with happiness
overwhelmingly it's nothing about belief
it's participation in a community on a
weekly basis especially a community that
has some sort of moral principle some
sense of uplifting some sense of
self-control binding moral
responsibility
and so actually this allows me to go
back to durkheim I dropped that name in
before but didn't really tell listeners
anything about him
so Emile durkheim
is one of the most important
sociologists in history he's writing in
France in the 1890s and early 1900s
and one of his early works is this
incredible study of suicide now this is
when European countries are just
beginning to collect statistics and he
goes through all the data he can get on
suicide in different countries in Europe
and he's looking for what makes the
suicide rate go up and down and he
treats the suicide rate as a thing in
itself it's a sociological fact it's an
emergent fact about a country its rate
goes up and down what makes it go up and
down
well when you go to war the suicide rate
goes way down people are bound together
they don't kill themselves when you look
at who in a country kills themselves it
turns out if you're married you're less
likely to if you're mad with children
you're even less likely to
whereas if you're Protestant you're more
likely to but if you're Catholic or
Jewish you're less likely to
and over and over what he finds is the
degree to which people are bound into a
society the less likely they are to kill
themselves now East Asian cultures many
cultures you kill yourself because
you're too tightly bounded and you're
shamed but in Western cultures our
problem is anomie or normlessness you
have a sense of meaninglessness you're
not connected
that's why Americans and westerners kill
themselves mostly and so so back to
religion
if you're an atheist and you're not part
of a community and especially if you're
a new atheist and you're angry or
whatever but to protect the factor seems
to be being bound into relationships and
community and that fits with everything
else I know in psychology
the comment on wartime also makes me
think about
tribe by Sebastian younger which I oh
yeah highly recommend to people it it
really
underscores
the fragility of isolation and also the
fragility of fetishizing comfort in a
way
as I said I suggest people take take a
look at that
well Jonathan we've covered a lot here
I could ask many more questions but what
have I neglected to ask and I and I do
have a question about heresies of yours
in a moment but is there anything that
you would like to bring up that I have
not mentioned
yes we haven't talked about what's
happening to gen Z we haven't talked
about what's happening to kids
you know I talked about them before in a
sort of negative way like gen Z shows up
on campus and then all of a sudden
there's all these problems but but again
I don't get angry I'm not moralistic we
have to understand
what's happening to gen Z so I just want
to talk if I can just talk a little bit
about that and could you also Define gen
Z
yeah and then please continue so
Millennials are those who were born in
1982 and we used to think that it would
go to maybe two thousand but it turns
out that kids were born in 1996 and
later are different from those born say
1994 and earlier I mean it's a
surprisingly sharp cut equivalent to
what we find with birth year in 1946 you
know the post-war world really was
different to grow up in and I believe so
I'm drawing on work by Gene twangy but
I've also added she and I are working
together and I've added a lot
what happened is that if you were born
in say 1990
you didn't get you couldn't you didn't
get an iPhone until maybe around 2009 is
when teenager at 10 is when teenagers
started getting it so if you're born in
1990 you didn't get an iPhone a
smartphone until you were 20.
and you didn't get on social media you
might have been on Facebook partly but
you don't live on social media until you
have your own smartphone
whereas if you're born in 1997
you are 13 in 2010 when you might get
your first smartphone and you might get
on Instagram
in 2012 when huge numbers did so I
believe gen Z is defined by the fact
that they got smartphones and social
media during early puberty there's a lot
of research pointing to early puberty
around 11 to 13 for girls 12 to 15 for
boys
what's coming into your brain then is
really important because your your
frontal cortex is wiring itself up so
when human beings are raised without
much Independence but yes with a phone
and they spend their childhood just
interacting with the screen and
especially social media
I believe it it messes up cortical
development
the girls in particular the rates of
anxiety and depression are more than a
much more than 100 since 2010 the rate
of self-harm hospitalization for
self-harm is nearly tripled
for pre-teen girls
so gen Z is in big big trouble
they're hurting they're fragile they're
not doing well in the workplace managers
are finding them very hard to work with
so we have a generation that's running
off the rails and this is not a
moralistic thing like oh those kids
these days this is a compassionate thing
like these are our children like my kids
are 13 and 16. everyone either has kids
or is you know is has nieces and nephews
so this is I think the greatest
emergency we Face the greatest Health
Emergency I think for kids this is much
much bigger than covet covid was a big
deal for old people it wasn't a big deal
for children in terms of the risk but
this is you know a doubling more than
doubling of suicide rates for kids since
2010. so that's what I'm working on now
what decisions have you made
in your parenting that you feel have
been perhaps
most impactful less typical or the Venn
diagram of those two overlapping
so the terrible mental health of gen Z
is caused by two factors one is the vast
overprotection kids need to practice
independent self-governance from the
time they're seven or eight they need
Independence but they don't get it
anymore
you and I when we were growing up you're
younger than me but I presume you were
allowed to roam around your neighborhood
I was a free range yeah riding bikes
everywhere when I was younger I was also
in a rural environment but yeah I was
out and about very early yeah so kids
must have free-range childhoods they
must Practice Independence and they had
that before the 90s and in the 90s
things got incredibly safe we locked up
the drunk drivers we took the perverts
off the street crime plummets but we
freaked out about child abduction
unnecessarily so in the 90s we stopped
letting kids out
and this affects gen Z in the late
Millennials anyway but you asked about
me so what my wife and I did we live in
here in New York City
in Greenwich Village
we because we're friends with Lenora
scenesi who wrote this fantastic book
free-range kids
we let our kids out to play in
Washington Square Park we sent them out
on errands when they were eight nine
years old
you know New York City was very safe
back then it's a little more dangerous
now but it was very very safe in the
2010s and we sent them out and we had
them walk to school way you know a year
or two before before anyone else was
doing it so I'm very glad we did that
we also made it clear no social media at
least until High School absolutely none
in Middle School
then that's been very good when they
start sixth grade my kids tell me
everyone's on Instagram and we said no
you we're not going to let you do it
the one mistake I made was that when my
son wanted Fortnight in sixth grade
and we said no
because video games can be addictive
I but now that I've dug into the
literature a lot more now I see that yes
a lot of boys do get in trouble from
video games because they're on it so
much they're addicted to it and it
pushes out everything else but a couple
hours a day
for boys
to be in a group that's battling other
boys it turns out that's actually a good
thing and my son was somewhat cut off in
sixth grade good in what respects how is
that assessed just in terms of acting as
a release valve for aggression or social
cohesion group dynamics so the release
valve idea from Freud does not
to end up being true kids don't need to
blow off aggression it's not like that
it's rather that girls and boys each
need to practice their gendered
behaviors this is what play is play for
all mammals is a way you practice in
childhood the skills you'll need as an
adult and so boys and girls have very
different play boys tend to break up
into groups to compete with other groups
and multiplayer video games allow them
to do that so I'm not saying these are
great I'm saying
ideally the kid should be out having
Adventures but given that all the kids
are home they're not allowed out until
they're you know 11 12 years old
so at least a multiplayer video game
allows them to be part of a group now
it's not a very creative group the rules
are all set by the company so it's not
like video games are anywhere near as
good as being at on their own but
they're not bad
until it gets to be heavy so
that was a small mistake once covet hit
we did let him get fortnite and then
that was the only way he talked with his
friends
so that was okay the mistake the one
mistake I think we did make was we
didn't we tried a few different summer
camps we never quite found one but if we
I wish we'd found a really good summer
and I would urge this for everybody
who's a parent of young kids from the
time your kid is about eight or nine
certainly
I'd say eight find a Sleepaway Camp that
is pretty unstructured and unsupervised
the kids have to have a lot of
Independence you know some summer camps
now are sober protective you can't go to
the bathroom unless you have an escort
and sometimes you need two escorts
because what if one escort falls down
and gets hurt like it's crazy
overprotective everywhere but if you can
find a summer camp
that is not crazy or protective send
your kid there every summer that I think
is one of the few chances they really
have to develop skills to be out in the
woods so I wish we'd done that
I was fortunate in that respect I got
sent off to summer camps in Wyoming
where we would work on ranches yeah that
sounds great got kicked by horses
I mean I didn't suffer any terrible
injuries but it wasn't free of injuries
but that was okay nothing was
cataclysmic and that I think combined I
mean if I don't have kids but if if I do
and I hope I do at some point I also
think
a year abroad in a critical window
similar to mine yes because of that
forced Independence
and there are other reasons or other
compelling reasons but I I came back a
fundamentally different person in terms
of my confidence in my abilities to
handle uncertainty and to adapt
it was just night and day complete
complete phase shift that's right that's
how kids learn to manage risk for
themselves you learn to be a risk taker
when we overprotect kids we're not doing
them any favors we're not keeping them
safe we're increasing their odds of
anxiety and depression self-harm and
suicide and we're depriving them of the
ability to judge risks for themselves
they're going to be less successful less
likely to start businesses no we've
really messed up gen Z I feel like one
other unexpected
blessing in my life was was
transitioning from a very bad public
school on Long Island to a very good
boarding school in New Hampshire which
was actually largely my idea
encouraged by teachers a handful of of
good teachers at the
pretty low quality public school on Long
Island who effectively said you you
should try to get out of here so I do
owe them thanks
when I went to the boarding school which
was very similar to let's say a Dead
Poet Society type of setup but class is
six days a week
mandatory Sports
and looking back the mandatory Sports I
think was the force multiplier
that allowed everything else to go more
smoothly on so many levels so if I get
to the point I hope I do when I'm
parenting I think I think physical
activity in group Sports will be what
will probably play a compelling role I
don't know if there's any research to
support that there is but just two
points I think you're basically right
but just two points of nuance
one is to the extent that it's heavily
supervised and there's a coach it's less
nutritious they're not going to learn as
much the ideal is for kids to be out
making up their own games enforcing the
rules because then
you have to keep the game going you have
to learn how to adapt to other kids
whereas if there's a coach or a referee
then what you learn is how do I get the
referee to come in on my side and that's
good preparation for college today where
if somebody says something how do I get
a Dean to punish him but that's bad
preparation for life
well that's the first thing second thing
so I just came across a finding that
participation in individualist sports
like gymnastics and especially ballet is
bad it actually is conducive to bad
mental health I would never let my
daughter do ballet
but team sports where you're you know
soccer basketball where you really
functioning as a team over and over
again those have very good effects on
mental health and development so I would
agree with that
yeah you know my so my sport was
wrestling which was certainly an
individual sport
practiced in a team context you would
have wrestling partners and so on
I would have a child do wrestling I
think now I'd have them where I'd have
them wear headgear because I don't think
cauliflower ears work terribly well for
most people it goes doubly for females I
would say and if you haven't seen
cauliflower ears on female ears it is
scar tissue that will not go away unless
surgically removed I saw a lot of it in
Japan in Judo players male and female
lots of cauliflower ears but I found it
to be for me personally at least
a
excellent venue for proving to myself
that I could exceed the limitations I
thought I had and in terms of
work capacity and pain tolerance also I
will say critical critical components so
I can't totally with any conviction say
that it was wrestling that did this
although I have some belief that it
contributed the coach John Buxton
changed the lives of almost every
athlete he coached and to this day I'm
still close to him and many people in
that wrestling team went on to do some
some pretty outstanding things and they
they have all to my knowledge just about
all of them have mentioned
Mr Buxton we we have a tough time
calling him John I have to ask you a
question yeah did you have a tough
coaching style but did you have like a
warm nurturing style he was extremely
extremely tough and this is what I was
going to bring up he was extremely tough
he did not suffer fools gladly at all if
if people
complained about something they could
fix themselves or should try to fix
themselves he did not tolerate it he
was a very tough coach good that's what
I expected and he was a very very very
good performer so he himself had been an
outstanding wrestler and could go
toe-to-toe with anyone in the group
including people who went on to
become all-americans I mean granted in
in their particular corner of the
wrestling world
and
exceptionally tough and he would give
occasional positive feedback
and I don't want to say he was stingy
but you've really had to earn it you
really really had to earn it that's what
I figured wrestling is probably the best
anti-fragile sport there is that is more
than any other sport wrestling is really
going to be about developing your
anti-fragility your strength in the face
of adversity testing your strength so
the sport itself is very conducive to
growth in that way
and I kind of knew given how grateful
you were I kind of knew that he was
going to be a tough coach not not a warm
nurturing coach
because you really need to get the full
benefit of the growth into strength you
need someone to push you you need
someone with high standards you need
someone to enforce those standards you
need to strive for them
a few years ago when I gave a talk on
the coddling the American mind I was
sitting next to somebody who'd been I
think the head of the NCAA
or high up in it and this was like 20s
2018 2019 he said the tough coaching
style is no longer
it's not that it's banned but it's that
coaches are fine and they can't use the
tough style anymore because the kids
will cry they'll report them they'll say
no you know you need to be nurturing and
so tough coaching I think is going out
because what if you hurt a kid's
feelings and so in so many ways we've
accepted and that's great on Truth
number one of the Kylie American mind is
what doesn't kill you makes you weaker
now that's wrong that's a falsehood but
that's what many people now believe and
I think your experience really shows
that no what doesn't kill you makes you
stronger that's what Nisha said and
that's what the psychology supports so
you know I think for the lesson here for
parents and teachers is we need to have
standards we need to push kids to meet
the standards sometimes the kids are not
going to be happy and as long as we can
be reported for pushing the kids we're
not going to push the kids and the whole
generation goes down the tubes so that's
what we're doing yeah and Coach Buxton
also fundamentally believes I'll speak
for myself personally I don't want to
speak for other folks but
he would reinforce the belief that he
saw in me the capacity to do more to
perform better
and it was in that context that being a
tough coach
was the nice thing to do does that make
sense yeah the service of realizing that
unrealized potential and I think all of
the athletes he coached felt that way
that he saw something in us that we
couldn't easily see and he was pushing
us
to unlock that potential and it was it
so it was not abusive for the sake of
say breaking someone down like perhaps a
drill sergeant might serve the function
of like shared privation and that type
of environment I think there's a purpose
to that and I think it actually can be
good for the collective but in this
particular wrestling context
the the Wellspring
of the toughness
came from a place of
in some cases explicitly saying you can
do better and I know you can do better
yeah
and that was powerful it's very powerful
and that is beautiful I think what
you've just done there is you've stated
what the Telos of teaching should be
Telos is this Greek word that I'm very
fond of nowadays it means the end or
purpose for which something is done you
know the Telus of medicine is Health
what is the Telos of a university and
I've been focusing on the research
aspect where artillos is truth but we're
also teachers and artillos as teachers
is not truth and I've been saying oh you
know it's the education of our kids it's
learning teaching but I think what you
said is actually better the Telos of a
teacher is doing this service of
realizing their untapped potential
that's what we're trying to do that's
what we should be trying to do we don't
always do it yeah I've been very
fortunate in that respect to have had a
handful of teachers who were
unrelenting in their
pushing towards the truth that they saw
which was their students could in fact
do the hard things
and that was true I I'll give thanks to
another teacher Professor Shimano
who was my first Japanese teacher and
surprise surprise when I transferred
from Spanish to Japanese I found
Japanese to be extremely difficult
and I almost quit I want to say twice
once just because of the the difficulty
with the language grammatically and the
second time when we started delving into
the various writing systems in Japanese
and I was talked off the ledge
by
Professor Shimano who was able to just
say like give it some time I think you
can do this
and I'm betting that I can help you do
this and good God if I had not
if I had not listened to that if I had
pushed back if I had become offended and
walked from that class my life would not
be what it is today in in any respect so
I feel very very grateful let's talk
just a little bit if there's anything
that you'd care to add about
intellectual anti-fragility are there
other things that people can do other
practices they can experiment with other
resources that you would suggest they
look to to develop intellectual
anti-fragility
so I created a resource and online
resource with Caroline Mel
who was working with me originally at
heterox Academy but we branched out
if listens go to constructive
dialogue.org
we've created a program called
perspectives that kind of walks you
through some of the moral psychology
like why are we like this why are we so
tribal why do we have confirmation bias
and it teaches you
it teaches you how to open your mind and
open your heart and it teaches you how
to engage with people
and how to learn from them how to listen
so all the things we've been talking
about if you go to constructive dialogue
and yes dialogue is
d-i-a-l-o-g-u-e dot org we have a
program that we created called
perspectives it used to be called open
mind
and if listeners go there it was
designed for use in college courses like
especially at orientation because if
everyone in a group has these Concepts
and they use these tools you're gonna
have great discussions you can be able
to talk about hard things it works
really well in businesses as well so
that's one resource
another resource I think what I found
really helped me when I was writing the
Righteous Mind was I just subscribed to
the best writing on the other side so I
was very much on the left when I started
the book and I would read the new
Republic the New York Times were things
I read back when the new Republic was a
good magazine
but I subscribed to National Review and
the Wall Street Journal and National
Review has all these really smart
center-right intellectuals great writing
and I found it and I would read about
current events like for you know on the
left and the right it just I just
understood things much better you know
it's kind of trite but you literally
can't understand something from looking
at a single perspective you kind of have
to walk around it and look at it from
all sides so resources are out there and
the internet is such that
it will guide you to Fantastic resources
from each perspective and if you don't
seek them out then what you get if
you're on the left you do encounter some
conservative ideas but usually you
encounter reports of them in their worst
form or you report to them being held up
to ridicule and same thing if you're on
the right
so yeah if you want to be smarter and
stronger
yeah you must seek out different
perspectives it's kind of trite but
there it is so constructive dialogue.org
and we'll link to all of these in the
show notes and I'll also create a URL by
the time this comes up it'll work which
will just be Tim dot blog slash height h
a i d t and that will forward to this
episode so people can find all the links
in the show notes really easily
let me ask you the billboard question
I'm curious what your take on this might
be the billboard question
is sometimes a dead end and I'll take
full blame for that if it is but if you
could put a message a quote
anything at all on a billboard
metaphorically speaking to get something
out to billions of people assuming they
would all understand it
what might you put on that billboard
Ah that's actually easy I'm gonna
nominate two if you if you'll give me
the front the back of the billboard I'll
give you two okay so the first is a
quote from a Zen Buddhist philosopher in
the 8th century
was his name Chinese Buddhist
philosopher and I've used this quote in
most of my books he says the perfect way
is only difficult for those who pick and
choose do not like do not dislike all
will then be clear
make a hair breath difference and Heaven
and Earth are set apart if you want the
truth to stand clear before you never
before or against the struggle between
for and against is the mind's worst
disease
so this is what we were talking about
before about about getting Beyond
moralism
when you're moralistic when you're
judging when you're saying this is good
this is bad you get stupider you don't
understand the Nuance of things so so
this quote is about sort of
demoralization not like being
demoralized but like sucking the
moralism or the morality out of
something and just trying to understand
it
so that's the first
and then if I have the back of the
billboard I would put this quote from
Joseph Campbell so Joseph Campbell was a
professor at I think it was Bryn Mawr or
Sarah Lawrence rather
in the late 20th century he studied
myths and there was a wonderful PBS
series on the I think the hero with a
thousand faces was one of his books and
so Campbell that so this motto this
really calms me because I'm very alarmed
at the way things are going the way our
complex dynamical system is kind of
veering into chaos
and I found this quote to be really
really comforting I sort of have it up
on my walls various places
he says the lesson from his studying of
Heroes myths Heroes Journey stories
around the world is this quote
participate joyfully in the Sorrows of
the world
we cannot cure the world of Sorrows but
we can choose to live in joy the
Warrior's approach is to say yes to life
yes to it all
so that's that's what I put up
love it that's a great combination
and
you mentioned Buddhism and stoicism
earlier I don't know if you feel this
way but I have felt over time that
there's tremendous overlap
oh yeah in those two let's just call it
lineages or broadly speaking schools of
thought
and
I suppose
both are also related to your front and
back of the billboard in the sense of
cultivating
equanimity
a sense of being unperturbed by the
the vicissitudes if I could use a fancy
word yeah
of Life The Daily flux all of these tiny
and large tragedies that befall everyone
at various points
when do you or how do you
revisit some of these practical
philosophies
for yourself let's just let's just say
that you're going through a period or
there's an event where you you start to
feel disregulated consumed by oh yeah
emotions what do you do
thank you for that that's what you know
earlier you asked me like do I have
practices
so beginning you know there was the
summer of 2017 I think it was when Trump
was like threatening nuclear war against
you know there's a possibility like with
Northern nuclear war North Korea
and I really thought like he I think he
might actually want to do it I was
really thinking like this really could
be the end of the world
and and it was then that I started like
rereading stoic writings in the morning
and my favorite my favorite two are
Marcus Aurelius meditations the Gregory
Hayes translation is I think the best
one
and then also Epictetus is collected
works and what I do whenever I read I do
all my reading electronically now and
because I like to copy out text sites so
I copy my favorite lines out into an
Evernote file and so what I do in the
mornings I even have it in my calendar
let me see what how do I record in my
calendar every day repeating there's a
couple different things I do but it's
basically either reading stoicism or
Buddhism
or reflecting on Psychotherapy I've been
in therapy for for a while and
so yes I have it right here yes stooker
Buddhist reading and you have to check
it off each morning
and I do that before I check email
before anything else
and right you're right stoicism or
Buddhism they're very very similar
except stoicism is sort of like a
western version because it is more about
action in the world now Buddhism there's
you know there are buddhisms that are
very much in the world there are those
that pull you away more
but there is a sort of Eastern
sensibility like in taoism about like
don't do anything just settle just let
the world arrange itself and westerners
are not like that and stoics are not
like that but it is like acting that
we're like okay you're the emperor of
Rome you know but you're still getting
upset about things and you have to like
everything's crazy around you but it's
not just for Emperors Epictetus was a
slave and so it actually works at any
level of society you can never control
everything even if you're the emperor so
both of them
are just incredibly psychologically wise
ways of living in a world that you can't
control
and maintaining not just your economity
but even the capacity to be open
open-hearted and loving there's very
similar passages about
not necessarily loving your enemies but
actually sometimes it is like but and
they both use the same technique of
saying and remember you'll both be dead
before long like that's a quote from the
dhamapada like you know how can you
quarrel remember you're knowing that
you'll both be dead before long it's all
trivial
how long is your document that you
review in the morning that Evernote file
well you know I've got a whole big one
for Seneca who I'm going through Seneca
there's just so much writing and it's
not as dense in terms of gems but you
know I've got one for every T this one
for Aurelius one for Buddha
and if you go to actually on you know
what on the if you go to the
coddling.com which is the web page for
the for the cuddling of the American
mind and you go to Solutions better
mental health I've actually put up at
the bottom I've put up a collection of
sayings by Mark cyrillius that basically
are about the three great untruths of
the book so here's one
today I escaped from anxiety or no I
discarded it because it was Within Me In
My Own perceptions not outside
so this is the great on truth that we
cover in the book is always trust your
feelings
but what the Buddhists and the stoics
and CBT tell us is no don't always trust
your feelings question them sometimes
they're legitimate but sometimes they're
gross overreactions to nothing
yeah so anyway yeah I found those are
the great wisdom traditions in my
opinion how long do you spend in the
morning if you check the box of that
calendar reminder with that reading
about 10 minutes 10 minutes and
sometimes I'll like recently I'm doing a
loving kindness meditation because I'm
very cerebral and I actually sort of
need to open my heart more I make you
know sort of a coffee substitute a very
sensitive caffeine so I'm experimenting
with like these mushroom-based things
anyway
so but I just I make
a hot beverage and then I sit and at my
on a comfortable sofa
and I just spent 10 minutes it just
because what I found is that my MBA
students I asked how many of you check
your phone before you get up to pee and
how many of you wait until you actually
gone into the bathroom and very few of
them wait it's like right away it's like
I'm still okay what and you know turn on
the stream turn on the stream have it
come in like no don't do that yeah
have a better boot up sequence for for
your morning exactly that's right John I
really appreciate all the time this has
been a lot of fun I've I've copious now
it's I've there are many things that I'm
going to be looking up and I think I
think the first will be on Liberty
chapter two I'm gonna I'm gonna check in
and give that a read and then I have
many others is there anything else that
you would like to say any closing
comments
any questions anything you'd like to
point my audience to that we haven't
mentioned or that we have mentioned any
complaints you'd like to Lodge anything
at all
my mission when I moved to stern you
know business school you know everyone
has a mission statements so I made a
mission statement my mission
is to use my research and that of others
in moral psychology to help important
institutions work better
and so and I've started various
organizations so if you're concerned
about universities please go to
heterodoxacademy.org and join if you're
an academic or support us financially if
you can
if you're concerned about people's
ability to talk to each other or you
need to to address conflict in your own
organization please go to constructive
dialogue.org
if you are a parent and you're you have
kids born after 1996 you have gen Z kids
please go to letgrow.org a site I
started with Lenore scenesi to encourage
free-range parenting
and so all three of those are non-profit
foundations we really need help I'm
trying hard to raise money for them so
please support us and all of them I hope
will help you solve problems in your own
lives in your own organizations and your
own families
perfect that's the perfect place to wrap
up and for everyone listening
all of these links I will gather and put
also in the show notes so they'll be
collected in one place and you can click
them to take yourself to all these
destinations Tim dot blog forward slash
height h a i d t on Twitter be careful
it's full contact sport out there at
John height and
jonathanheight.com John thank you so
much for taking the time and being so
game I really appreciate it oh thank you
this is rollick in good fun
and everybody out there be just a little
Kinder than as necessary don't believe
everything that you think ask questions
before you make strong statements and
thanks for listening